Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today, I’m going to explain an episode called
“The H0unds 0f Baskervi11e” from the Mystery
Crime show “Sherlock.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
At the beginning of the episode, we see a
little boy running up a hill through the woods.
He looks frantic and scared.
An old lady stops the kid, and asks if he
is okay.
The boy doesn’t say anything but yells in
fear.
The child’s name is Henry Knight.
Cut to twenty years later; Henry has grown
up into an adult.
He stands in the same woods in Dartmoor.
It turns out that 20 years ago, he had seen
his father got killed by a gigantic hound.
The incident has traumatized Henry for life.
Somewhere else in London, a detective named
Sherlock Holmes and his partner, John Watson,
are in their apartment.
Sherlock comes in with a weapon and blood
all over him.
He has just solved another case.
Sherlock is experiencing withdrawal; He has
to solve cases to keep him from smoking.
He throws stuff around the apartment, looking
for his secret stash of cigarettes and yelling
at John to find a case.
Just then, their doorbell rings.
In comes Henry.
He wants Sherlock to investigate the case
of his father’s death.
He and his father used to go for walks to
moor; the woods has a place called Dewer’s Hollow
That day, a massive animal had caught Henry’s
father; it dragged and killed him in front of Henry
He brings a news report on Baskerville, a
chemical and biological weapons research centre
in Dartmoor.
He's convinced that a monster brewed in the
Baskerville lab killed his father.
However, Sherlock believes that Henry has
just created a story to cope with his trauma,
so he dismisses him.
But just then, Henry tells him that after
years of trauma, yesterday, Henry has visited
the hollow where the killing occurred, and
found gigantic paw prints of a hound.
The fact that Henry called it a ‘hound’
instead of a ‘dog’ spikes Sherlock’s  interest.
So he and John leave for Dartmoor the following
morning.
The two check into a hotel ,and on their way,
see a tour guide boasting about the hound
to a group of tourists.
The hound had become a local legend, and helped
to grow the place’s tourism.
Meanwhile, Henry is at his therapist, Louise
Mortimer’s home.
This time, during the session, he reveals
to her that he sees the words ‘liberty’
and ‘in’, in relation to the night his
father was killed.
While checking into the hotel, John sees a
receipt of a large amount of meat supplied
to the hotel.
Thinking it is unusual, he takes the bill
with him.
The two then talk to the tour guide, who tells
them that he has seen the hound too.
He believes that the Ministry of Defence research
base, called the Baskerville created the hound,
as a defense mechanism during the war.
Ever since, the hound has been running around
in Dartmoor killing people.
The two then visit Baskerville.
They use Sherlock’s brother, Mycroft’s
security pass to get access into the building.
However, the establishment is highly protected,
so they have only about twenty minutes before
they get caught.
One of the guards there offers the two a full
tour of the place.
They meet a lab doctor named Dr. Bob Frankland
while touring.
They walk around the labs, but do not find
any useful information about the hound, before
Mycroft’s card causes a security alert.
The major is about to run an identity check
on them when suddenly, Dr Frankland claims
to know him, and backs up Sherlock's ruse.
Turns out Franklin is a fan of Sherlock's
work, and he knows Henry and knew that they
came to help him.
Frankland says he was a friend of Henry's
father and is concerned for Henry's well-being.
The duo then visits Henry’s home in Dartmoor.
Henry offers them some tea, and tells them
of the words that he keeps seeing in his dreams,
“liberty” and “in”.
Sherlock’s next plan is to visit the Dewer’s
Hollow at night, and investigate the presence
of the hound.
The three make their way to the place in the
evening that day.
As they walk, John hears a noise coming from
the bushes behind him.
He separates from the group and investigates
the noise.
There, he sees a light flashing from far away.
It looks like someone is trying to communicate
in morse code.
John looks behind to call Sherlock, but they
have already walked far.
John decodes the morse, and finds that it
is saying “U-M-Q-R-A”.
Unsure of what that means, he goes back looking
for Sherlock and Henry.
The other two have already reached the Dewer’s
hollow; Sherlocks goes inside the pit to check.
As he looks around, he sees a massive animal
on the edge of the pit.
Henry sees it too.
Nervous, Henry comes running to Sherlock...
asking if he saw it too.
The two then get out of the pit and meet John.
Henry tells John that they saw the hound,
but Sherlock insists that he did not.
Henry is frustrated by Sherlock’s denial;
he is sure that Sherlock saw it too and is
happy to find that he did not make the hound
up.
Later, John and Sherlock are in a restaurant.
Sherlock doesn’t talk and looks nervous.
As John tells him about the morse code, Sherlock
interrupts him to tell him that he actually
saw the hound too.
He denied seeing it earlier to hide the fact
that he was scared.
John tries calming him, suggesting he is imagining
things.
Sherlock reacts with anger, insisting that
he is in a good mental state.
The two get into a fight, after which John
walks away from him.
Outside the restaurant, he sees the same morse
code blinking far away in the hills.
He sets off to look for the source.
Finally, he finds that they were just headlights
from flashes from a group of doggers.
Embarrassed, he returns back.
Henry is back home when he suddenly wakes
up at night.
Suddenly, he starts to hallucinate the night
his father was killed.
He sees the words ‘liberty’ and ‘in’
repeatedly.
He tries watching TV ,but every show has some
kind of dog in it.
Suddenly, the out light turns on and off.
Henry gets his gun out.
Just then there is a bang on the glass door.
The lights start to flicker again.
Scared, he falls to the floor.
The following day, Sherlock makes John go
on a date with Henry’s therapist, Louise Mortimer.
John tries getting information out of her
without revealing his true intention.
The pair share a flirty drink as they chat
about Baskerville and the hound, but Dr Franklin
ruins the mood when he exposes John as a professional
investigator.
Louise leaves right after.
The following morning, Sherlock goes to Henry’s
home.
He is overly excited which sets Henry off.
He has not slept in days because of his night
terrors.
Sherlocks directly runs to the kitchen to
make himself a coffee, and starts looking
through the cabinets.
Henry asks him why he denied seeing the hound
the other day, but Sherlock dismisses it.
Instead, he questions Henry why the creature
is called ‘Hound’.
Before he can let Henry answer, Sherlock abruptly
leaves the place and sees John writing something
on his notepad.
While talking, Sherlock realizes something.
He suggests that the word hound is actually
an acronym that stands for something.
John is confused but goes with his friend’s
theory.
Just then, Sherlock runs into DI Lestrade,
who he suspects has been sent to Dartmoor
by his brother Mycroft.
Meanwhile, John reveals a clue he discovered
earlier - inside the inn where he and Sherlock
are staying, is a receipt for a large delivery
of meat, even though the bar and restaurant
is strictly vegetarian.
The innkeeper admits that he briefly kept
a wild dog on the moor - disguising it as the famous hound
to boost tourism.
However, he insists that the creature's been
put down a month ago, and in any case, it
bears little resemblance to the monstrous
creature that Sherlock and Henry encountered...
After that, Sherlock claims that he has a
theory, but has to go to Baskerville to test it.
They cannot pull the fake card trick again,
so Sherlock calls his brother who provides
him with access to Baskerville again.
He plans to distract the Major as soon as
they get inside.
Then, he wants John to check all the labs
for the glowing hound.
John is investigating the labs, and goes further
in the labs than they did last time.
Suddenly, a lab light flashes onto his eyes.
He hears a ringing noise.
The light keeps on shining brighter and the
ringing gets worse.
John tries to get out of the place but his
key card stops working.
Suddenly, the lights go off and the ringing
stops.
The room is pitch dark.
John then hears a noise and looks for it around
the lab.
He notices a broken cage.
Some animal might have broken out.
Just then he hears a growl.
He runs to the door again and uses his card
but to no avail.
The growling starts to get louder so he locks
himself in a cage to save him from the animal.
Just then, Sherlock calls him.
He frantically tells Sherlock to come and
save him.
Sherlock asks him if he can see the hound,
John answers that he does.
Just then, Sherlock turns the lights on and
lets John out.
John tries to explain to Sherlock that he
saw the hound, but Sherlock dismisses him,
saying that he was drugged.
Sherlock then goes to see another doctor from
the lab, Dr. Stapleton.
He borrows her microscope, and studies the
sugar from earlier.
Sherlock suspects that they have been drugged
to see the product of their imagination, that
is the hound.
He and Henry both had tea at Henry’s home,
before they went to the hollow that day.
He believes that the sugar they put into the
tea was drugged, because both Henry and he
saw the hound but John did not.
And John had not taken sugar with his tea.
Before coming to Baskerville, Sherlock has
given John coffee with the same sugar in it.
Hence, he hallucinated the hound in the lab.
However, as he checks the sugar, he can find
no trace of a narcotic.
Agitated, he throws it to the wall.
He then uses a mind technique that he likes
to call the ‘mind palace’.
While meditating, he deduces that ‘Liberty’
and ‘in’, actually mean Liberty Indiana;
and HOUND was a project at a CIA facility
in Liberty, Indiana.
After accessing confidential files, Sherlock
finally realizes the truth.
The project HOUND was established twenty years
ago in Indiana by a group of five researchers.
They had developed a new drug, intended to
be used as a weapon to disorientate the enemy.
However, the project was shut down because
of what it did to the subjects it was tested on.
It made the subject extremely violent, causing
many homicides.
The same drug had been given to Henry to make
him hallucinate.
The entire project was abandoned, but someone
has started it up again.
As Sherlock brainstorms who would do this,
he realizes that it is Dr. Frankland.
He has been in the field for a long time.
Moreover, Sherlock had picked up on his American
dialect; Dr. Frankland was in Indiana when
project Hound was running.
His obsession with the drug did not change
after moving to the UK.
Meanwhile, Henry is in his therapy session
with Louise when suddenly he fires at her,
hallucinating that she is the hound.
Thankfully he misses.
As he gets back to his senses, he realizes
what he has done; he apologizes to the doctor
and runs away taking the gun with him.
Just then, John gets a call from Louise who
informs him of Henry’s outburst earlier.
She informs that Henry has gone out with a
gun.
Sherlock deduces that he must have gone to
the Dewer’s Hollow.
When Sherlock and John reach there, Henry
is inside the pit, trying to kill himself.
Sherlock manages to talk him out of it, explaining
that the hound was a hallucination; Henry's
father was killed not by a devilish hound,
but by Frankland, who was wearing a gas mask
with red-coloured lenses and a sweater with
the words "HOUND" and "Liberty In" on it.
Henry finally comes back to his senses.
But just then, the place starts to fog.
A huge hound appears on top of the pit.
Lestrade is there too.
The four start to panic, when Sherlock suddenly
sees Dr Frankland there.
Sherlock realizes that the fog was drugged
the whole time.
They kill the hound, and as the fog clears
up, Henry looks at the hound and realizes
that it is just an ordinary dog.
The fog had made them hallucinate.
Sherlock explains that pressure pads are installed
around the hollow, which released a dose of
the chemical compound, dosing Henry each time
he visited.
With Henry unstable and delirious, his credibility
was damaged, meaning his father's death and
the dubious experiments at Baskerville could
be covered up...
Henry realises that Frankland murdered his
father, because his father had found him continue
testing the drug on people.
He flies into a vengeful rage and attempts
to throttle Frankland, but the doctor escapes.
After a brief chase, Frankland runs into the
Baskerville minefield and steps on a mine,
killing himself in the explosion.
The next day, Sherlock and John are having
coffee, discussing the case.
John is confused as to why he saw the hound
in the lab, despite not having inhaled the
gas from the Moor.
Sherlock tries to explain that the pipes in
the lab must have been leaking the gas, but
John correctly guesses that it was Sherlock
who trapped him in the Baskerville lab; the
terrifying noises made by the 'hound' were
actually just sound effects played in by Sherlock,
as he attempted to test his theory; that the
hallucinogenic drugs had been planted in Henry's sugar
John also purposely reminds Sherlock of being
wrong when he previously deduced the drug
was in the sugar, which hits Sherlock's nerves;
he implies he won't get it wrong again another time.
At the last scene, we see Sherlock approaching
the innkeeper, implying that the innkeeper
lied about having his dog put down, it was
indeed his dog that the drugged Sherlock and
the others had perceived as the terrifying
beast.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on notifications, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thank you for watching.